Samsung is on a freakin roll lately and
I'll just come out and say it the Galaxy
Tab Essex is the best Android tablet
ever and I think some Apple users will
actually be better suited to buy this
instead of an iPad if Android tablets
we're anywhere near as close to this in
terms of quality a few years ago this
would have saved the industry as a whole
but I'm still very glad the Samsung is
not giving up this video is sponsored by
Squarespace an all-in-one platform that
makes it easy to make an amazing website
about four months ago I reviewed the
cheaper Galaxy Tab s5e and I've really
enjoyed using it but overall I couldn't
recommend it for most people because of
one reason which is no longer an issue
with the tab s6 and I'll talk about that
in just a bit if you like bang for the
buck
Samsung really delivers we have a
gorgeous 10.5 inch OLED HDR 10 plus
display it's not only capable of playing
1440p YouTube videos but also an HDR
which looks absolutely brilliant and
this is something that isn't supported
with the s5 II that along with the 16 by
10 aspect ratio makes it clearly more
suitable for video than the major tablet
brand base storage is at a proper amount
for 2019 128 gigabytes and that is
paired with six gigs of RAM but for a
reasonable $80 that can actually be
brought up to 256 gigs of storage with 8
gigs of RAM and if somehow you start
running out of room do not worry you can
add more storage later with cheap
microSD card expansion holding it in
your hands feels fantastic
that just started out flat then take on
a subtle curve which actually makes it
more comfortable in the hand than either
the iPad pro or the air it weighs only
430 grams and that with a five point
five millimeter thinnest makes it feel
almost weightless in your hands that's
practically the same weight as the s5 II
even though this has s-pen support and
other Hardware improvements I really
praise the s5 ease quad speakers which
bested all iPads and surprisingly Stamps
I managed to make them even better and
slightly louder Samsung went for an
under display fingerprint reader this
time and it's quite a bit faster and
more consistent than the ultrasonic
sensors in their flagship phones that is
because it's using an optical design
that requires a screen to be turned on
at first but I would definitely take
this trade-off for the faster and more
reliable sensor
one major value proposition is the
inclusion of the s-pen in the box which
has a button on it and is charged
magnetically on the back it stays in
place fairly well and won't fall off but
it can be bumped off when using it you
can also attach it on the side for quick
storage
I like the soft tip and it works fairly
well but there is noticeable lag
especially if you draw or write quickly
if you buy Samsung's keyboard there is a
magnetic slot which will keep it in
place perfectly
and in general I really like the
keyboard other than one complaint but
before that I have to give a shout out
to a company that I have absolutely no
complaints about our sponsor Squarespace
I've built many websites using
Squarespace and I've been recommending
them for over five years now I've made
websites from scratch custom templates
I've even tried multiple platforms and
Squarespace is by far my most
recommended method whether you're
wanting to build a portfolio site
ecommerce blog or anything else they
have got you covered with great
cross-platform designs to choose from
and built-in security certificates and
SEO tools this means that your website
will rank much better in searches and
that's all included for one low price
making Squarespace not only easy and
fantastic looking but also an amazing
value
head to squarespace.com / Mac stack for
a no credit card required trial and if
you sign up you will get 10% off your
first purchase of a website or a domain
Samsung's new keyboard is fairly
innovative for an Android tablet because
it features a multi-touch trackpad now
it is small and it does take some time
to get used to and even then it won't
match a great laptop but for those
looking for a laptop like experience it
is really nice to have especially with
Dex I absolutely love the kickstand
which is super adjustable with just the
right amount of tension this is much
more usable than the ipad pro's keyboard
and I love the fact that you can remove
the keys and just use the stand by
itself along with the s-pen holder the
actual keys themselves are just okay I
didn't love them at first but after
typing for about an hour so I started to
get used to them I really wish that they
were slightly larger especially for the
number keys and I wish they weren't as
kind of scrunched over to the left-hand
side to make room for those extra keys
also it is quite pricey the same price
as the ipad pro's keyboard but for those
who do a lot of typing it will be a
nobler
my biggest complaint with s5e was the
cpu and even more so the graphics which
limited performance and longevity
Samsung packed a Snapdragon 855 into
this thin chassis and while it's not as
powerful as the iPad pro which beats out
a lot of laptops the real-world
performance was quite good I added a
handful of 24 and 42 megapixel RAW
images with white room and it did
fantastic the only time I noticed it
being slower than an iPad pro is when
denoising through our images but even
that it was a slight difference
exporting 10 RAW images was actually
quite a bit faster with the tab at 6 I'm
not sure why but that was the case it
also performed quite well in games the
only time we noticed a difference was in
the most demanding titles like asphalt 9
and in most games it is very similar as
far as the experience now one area
dusting and out is the comfort when
you're gaming for a long time because of
those curved edges so all of this sounds
fantastic so far but where are the
downsides well mainly it is with Android
and not even with Android by itself but
the apps not being optimized for tablets
the hardware itself is fantastic but if
software developers aren't optimizing
the experience in apps your experience
is going to be worse than with iPad OS
which is much more popular overall in
Lightroom mobile the S Pen button didn't
do anything whereas with the Apple
pencil I could just tap it to swap tools
which is very convenient so this is my
one big issue with the Galaxy Tab s6 not
the hardware itself and that is great it
is top-notch but it is the software and
the optimizations which are really
holding back the screen tablet and to be
completely honest I'm really not sure
how much better this will get in the
future Samsung is doing a great job with
their own apps and of course web apps
were great so for most people this might
be more than enough but if you want
access to a huge library of apps that
are optimized for tablet use and for pen
use you might be out of luck now Samsung
has a secret weapon with their tablets
and that is decks which is a PC like
interface that cannot be used with or
without a display this is great if you
want to be very flexible with
multitasking and unlike the iPads you
can actually use it with full mouth
support and of course now the trackpad
which
fantastic so to start wrapping all of
this up if you know that you want an
Android tablet definitely get this one
it is well worth the extra cash over the
tab s5e but if you're on the fence
between going with say ns6 or an ipad
that is going to be a tough choice
personally I would definitely choose the
tab s6 over an iPad air but not over the
iPad pro I do like the tab a6 more
especially for things like web use video
washing music and other simple laptop
like uses especially with that trackpad
and it is also a better value with more
storage coming with the base and the S
Pen being included but the iPad has a
few standout features that a 12x is an
absolute beast and performance making
game smoother and that 120 Hertz screen
and the Apple pencil makes writing and
drawing a much smoother lag-free
experience the biggest one of all is the
app optimization there are just so many
great optimized apps available with more
and more coming out and that matters a
whole lot right now you can actually
pick up an iPad pro for 674 dollars
inside of 800 which does help close the
gap value-wise
I'll go ahead and leave a link down to
that deal in the video description but
if you're somebody that knows that you
absolutely do not want an iPad that is
totally fine
the tab of 6 is the perfect choice for
you I think you will not be disappointed
especially with the hardware
you're gonna love almost everything
about it but make sure you do expect
some hiccups especially with third-party
apps thank you guys for watching if you
want to see more videos like this one
click that little circle above and also
that notification bell and if you guys
want to see our other comparison videos
with the s6 going against the s5 E or
the iPad pro you guys can click right
over there this has been max with max
sec and I will see you in the next video
[Music]